[Musique]
c'est l'histoire d'une bande de francs
comtois originaire du territoire de
belfort qui ont suivi les bleus pendant
les phases de poules en sillonnant
l'europe durant deux semaines à bord
d'un bus et qui donc aux abords des
stades ont déployé une banderole sur
laquelle ils ont associé le milieu des
bleus n golo quand tu es à leurs
spécialités régionales le comté ce qui
donne une banderole ngolo quand est ce
une gaule aux comptes et pardon sur
laquelle le joueur tient une demie
meules de comté dans ses bras à la
lessive de chars au même pas bien je
prends une douche ou b à malibu aux ges
en eau et sur les réseaux leur histoire
inspire peut-être un peu trop les
internautes puisque certains tentent
déjà d antoine briouze manhood et
killian m râpé mais les bonnes blagues
c'est comme les bons fromages il ya un
moment où il faut savoir dire stop et
donc ce soir allez le bleu on sait qu'on
n'a pas le droit à l'erreur
il y aura de l'adversité il y aura une
très très belle équipe face à nous qui
réalisent des très belles choses ces
dernières ces dernières saisons l'aspect
mental rentrer en jeu
c'est certainement la clé de la réussite
vous connaissez la douche écossaise
après la douche je suis ce soir la
france où malheureusement les bleus
qui est le tournoi dès les huitièmes de
finale une élimination trois bulles
partons donc à l'issue du temps du temps
terminal des prolongations et une séance
de tirs au but fatale aux bleus didier
deschamps
bonsoir on le sait il ya énormément de
déception parce que nos bleus étaient
favoris parce qu'on espérait tant que
cette équipe de france fasse un doublé
coupe du monde euro et finalement eh
bien on s'arrête se sont très rapidement
dans cette compétition
comment vous êtes devenu champion de
france de bien alors mes parents
tenaient un bar oui et donc du coup
c'était soit l'alcoolisme soit le bia
j'ai choisi le bien ça me semble très
bon choix
j'avais 7 ans y las vegas la ville de la
fête et des excès un anniversaire
célébré dans l'insouciance sans gestes
barrière s'est terminée en soins
intensifs
ce petit clip posté sur tik tok a été
réalisé par une jeune américaine c'est
sa mère qui est à l'hôpital et se bat
contre le coc vide
elle n'est pas vaccinée matt ngoc c'est
le ministre de la santé et anglais qui a
dû démissionner ce week-end à cause
d'une liaison extraconjugale oui et
c'est le très trash journal populaire le
sun qui a publié la photo vendredi on y
voit le ministre de la santé embrasser
goulûment une de ses assistantes dans
son bureau au ministère photos extraites
de la vidéo des caméras de sécurité
comme quoi il faut toujours se méfier de
la vidéosurveillance
je te promets que ça me fait vraiment
plaisir on s'agite
écoute j'espère que la semaine
commencera bien pour vous après vous
avez plein de découvertes
voilà toute la semaine et les chauriens
ski échoué c'est quand on voit se sont
élevées à 13 dans cette expérience
c'est vrai que j'ai vu l'instant présent
carpediem le problème c'est qu'il est en
première ligne depuis le début de la
pandémie c'est lui qui faisait les
conférences de presse quotidiennes
lui qui demandait toujours aux
britanniques de faire très attention et
de respecter les distances à sion
sociale en mai dernier il insistait
encore pour des c est pour des
conseillers tout contact physique avec
une personne ne faisant pas partie de
son foyer et cette injonction n'a été
levée que le 17 mai or la photo du
baiser dans le bureau du ministre date
du 6 mai est petit se faire draguer
n'ont même pas te faire dans la nature
je préfère prendre le contrôle toi
maintenant
non parce que ton prévient des
situations centaines ouais et du coup la
séduction pur dur ça me fait fuir comme
la peste
as tu déteste ça j'ai trop sa défense
parfaite et puis une pensée pour son
épouse qui a appris son infortune
vendredi juste avant la sortie du
journal et qui depuis est harcelé par
une dizaine de paparazzi qui n'ont pas
qu'ils n'ont pas quitté d'une semelle
pendant tout le week-end on y rentrer
chez nous on a été faire des courses et
en robe noire courte j'ai reçu un
message un message à marcq caen bonjour
jean paul heureusement que je n'ai pas
accepté avance pour un couple qui ne
fonctionne pas heureusement que je n'ai
pas accepté parce que tu m'as envoyé un
message je prends le numéro j'appelle
sylvie tellier qui va se faire à manger
à dire est qu'elle sort avec l'homme
invisible
au moins si nous la seule tu as dis moi
j'ai tous les messages je les ai pas
effacé j'ai envoyé moi les les messages
de toute façon le fis je sais vote non
madame
d'abord j'ai fait un coucou à evelyne ou
encore un support avec way
et puis j'ai eu d'écouté madame vous ne
voulez jean-paul je vous le donne mais
pas sa retraite parce que j'en ai pas
assez pour moi comme ça je suis parti au
front et j'ai couché avec tous ses potes
militaire j'ai passé les troupes en
revue à la vitesse de l'éclair sur le
trans pas je ne voulais pas je voulais
pouvoir une fois dans ma vie celui-là
comme ce qui nous arrive tout ceci n'est
pas là pour jouer
[Applaudissements]
non en fait je me demande souvent est ce
que quelqu'un que j'aime énormément
si tu quelqu'un et qui me demandent de
cacher le cada parce que c'était une
erreur
est ce que j'aiderai a caché le cadavre
je pense que oui est ce que ça fait de
moi un coupable déjà sans doute est ce
que je vais en prison après ce
questionnaire ça paraît beaucoup
est ce que j'y vais quand même sûrement
et donc je peux voir au quai 3 je t'aime
mon âge on s'inquiète la de ne me quitte
et un je t'aime de tout mon coeur je
peux regarde
[Musique]
avec ses parents à ma choquer quoi ces
cas aux cocos késako
dawa et aucun cas où quand j'ai dit tu
vois les allées l est
voilà c'est pas où ils veulent accoler
mettre dans le bon